KURT: Good morning everyone, and
welcome to our Talks at Google
talk on electric vehicles,
electric and plug-in vehicles.
I'm pleased to welcome--
when I massacre your name,
you'll correct me--
Gina Coplon-Newfield.
She directs the Sierra Club's
environmental electric vehicles
initiative which works on
the national and state levels
to advocate for electric
vehicle consumer initiatives
and educates the media,
policy makers, and the public
about the benefits
of plug-in vehicles.
Brian Cali is the co-founder
of Ironwood Pharmaceuticals
and has served as
the senior vice
president of pre-clinical
research and development
since 2010.
Both these people are
members of the Sierra Club.
Both of them own
plug-in vehicles.
And I'd like you to say
good morning to them
and we'll get going
with the talk.
[APPLAUSE]
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
Good morning everybody.
It's great to be here.
I use Google products
all the time.
So thank you so much for
making my life so much easier.
And I happen to live
right here in Cambridge.
And as Kurt said, work
for the Sierra Club
which is headquartered in
California just like Google is.
But I happen to work here.
And also as Kurt said,
I'm a proud driver
of a plug-in vehicle.
So as you may know,
the Sierra Club
is the oldest and largest
grassroots environmental
organization in the country.
We were founded in the
late 1800s by John Muir.
We have 2.4 million members
and supporters and chapters
in all 50 states.
We work on a range of different
environmental issues including
wilderness protection
and a range of campaigns
that are confronting
climate change.
Oil is one of the most
serious threats that we face.
Oil consumption
constitutes about 40%
of US climate emissions.
And as we all know,
climate emissions
are leading to some
pretty serious problems
in terms of increased storms,
droughts, fires, extreme
weather, floods, et cetera.
So I don't know about you,
but these kinds of things
do keep me up a
little bit at night
when I think about my children
and future grandchildren.
Climate change is a
clear and present danger
that we're facing.
And so oil is a
big part of that.
We also know that we're spending
between a quarter and a half
a billion dollars every
day to pay for foreign oil.
Often sending money
to countries that
are not necessarily
friendly to US policies.
And we also know that
there are examples
like during the height of
the fighting in Afghanistan,
we heard from the
Secretary of the Navy
that out of every
24 fuel convoys that
were being guarded
by US soldiers,
one Marine or soldier was
getting injured or killed
for every 24 of
these fuel convoys.
So that's a pretty heavy price
that we're paying for oil.
Fortunately, there are
alternatives to oil.
So we can get around, we can
move without having to use oil.
So for those of you
who bike to work,
maybe not on a freezing
day like today, but maybe.
Maybe there were some
brave people out there,
or walk to work,
or took-- oh good,
a brave person in the audience--
or took public transit,
those are clearly the
cleanest ways to get around.
But we know that millions
of people in this country
and around the world
will continue to drive.
So we need to find cleaner
ways to get around in our cars
without having to rely on
any oil or as much oil.
So I love this graphic that
really makes it tangible.
You think about the BP
Gulf oil disaster that
happened a few years ago and
you think about all the oil
that went into the
Gulf of Mexico.
And if we had a million
electric vehicles on the road,
that would be saving
the same amount of oil.
So how many people
in the audience
saw the State of the
Union Address last night?
Excellent, some fellow
policy nerds like me
who love that sort of thing.
So this is a quote from
President Obama's State
of the Union Address
four years ago
when he said, "we can
break our dependence on oil
and become the first
country to have
one million electric vehicles
on the road in 2015,"
Now it is 2015.
It is four years later now.
Will we have one million
electric vehicles on US roads
by the end of this year?
No.
We will not, unfortunately.
So we will not meet this goal.
But we will have
somewhere around 400,000
electric vehicles on the
road by the end of the year.
And we think we'll hit that
one million mark around 2018.
So EVs, or electric vehicles,
are gaining market share faster
than hybrids gained market
share when they first
hit the market
about 15 years ago.
So that's encouraging.
The Obama administration
has definitely
invested in electric vehicles
through the Department
of Energy's research, through
grants and programs that
are supporting public charging
stations around the country.
And through the
federal tax credit.
If you bought an
electric vehicle,
you would get somewhere
between $2,500 and $7,500
in a federal tax break,
which is certainly
nothing to sneeze at in
terms of an incentive.
So we're very fortunate to
have an administration that's
really supportive of this issue.
So now is an exciting time.
Four years ago when President
Obama give that speech,
there were almost no electric
vehicles on the road.
Now there are more
than a quarter million
and there are about 20
models that are available.
Not all of these models are
available in Massachusetts
but a lot of them are.
So there's the BMW i3,
there's the plug-in Prius,
there is the Nissan LEAF, the
Chevy Volt, the Tesla Model S.
All the different Ford models,
the Ford Fusion, the Ford
C-Max.
So there are a lot of
great options out there.
Raise your hand if you've driven
in an electric vehicle before?
OK.
Fantastic.
Raise your hand if you actually
own one or drive one yourself.
Great.
Oh good.
A couple examples.
So if you've been
in one before, you
know these are really fun cars.
They're quiet,
they're fast, they're
very technologically advanced.
They are easier and
cheaper to maintain
than a conventional
vehicle because there
are fewer moving parts involved.
And they're just
really fun to drive.
We talk in the electric
vehicles world a lot
about getting butts in
seats because so many people
out there just don't realize
that they're available
or they think they're
this futuristic thing that
aren't accessible to
real normal people.
But once you get
inside one and you
drive it or you ride in one you
know that this is, it's here.
It's available now and
it's a lot of fun to drive.
They don't necessarily work for
everybody's lifestyle, right?
So if you live in an
apartment building where
you don't have any
access to parking,
or a driveway, or garage where
you could plug the car in,
it's going to be challenging
to have an electric car.
Now if you have a place to plug
it in at work or around town
and that's convenient
for you, great.
That could work out.
But for some people, they're
just not going to work.
But the Union of Concerned
Scientists and consumer's union
did a survey a year or so ago
and they found that almost half
of Americans actually could
make an electric vehicle
work for their lifestyle.
So more people than
one might think
could be ready for an electric
car as their next car.
So I'll list just a few
examples of some of the things
that Sierra Club is doing to
advance electric vehicles.
As I said, we're
working on this issue
because we see oil and climate
change as really important
issues to address and electric
vehicles as one key way
to address those problems.
So we're doing a few things.
So one is public education.
So we have public events.
We've been having National
Drive Electric Week.
These are opportunities to
have electric vehicle promotion
events all around the country.
So last year we had
National Drive Electric Week
in September where we had EV
promotion events in 150 cities
around the country.
We got 90,000 or so people to
attend, about 200 media hits.
So it was just a really
good way to educate
the masses, or at least
some segment of the masses,
about electric cars.
We do blogging and
media outreach.
We have a website.
We also do policy advocacy.
So I mentioned the federal
tax credit, which is helpful.
But it's also helpful to
have states incentives.
So for example,
state rebates that
are on top of the
federal tax credit.
And I'll mention the
Massachusetts one
in a few minutes.
Carpooling access.
If you live in
California, you know
that those carpooling
stickers are like gold.
There is literally a black
market for these stickers
because people are so
desperate to get out
of traffic and the
hours and hours
that they spend in traffic.
So if you can have that carpool
lane sticker, even if you're
the only one driving as an
electric-vehicle driver,
that's like gold.
So having those kinds
of carpool-lane access
in other states, that is
really helpful as well.
A waiver on parking registration
or emissions tests, these kinds
of small things we found
can make a difference.
So getting more of them
in place in more states,
like Massachusetts,
is definitely
going to help accelerate the
electric vehicles market.
In fact, who knows the number
one state right now per capita
for electric vehicle sales?
So I'll give you a hint.
It is not California and
it is not Massachusetts.
It is Georgia.
And the reason it is
Georgia is because there
is a really generous
credit for driving
an electric car in Georgia.
There's a significant discount
for driving an electric car
there because there's
this incentive in place.
And so these incentives
definitely make a difference.
So just to give
you a little sense
of the scale of how fast
we need to ramp up demand,
we hired a consulting
firm to help
us evaluate how we can
make the biggest impact
and how fast we need to
accelerate this market.
And what they
helped us understand
is that by the year
2025, we're expecting
to have about four million
electric cars on the road.
Now think about the fact that
we have about 250 million cars
registered in this country,
cars and light trucks.
So that's still a very small
sliver of the vehicle market.
Now with an aggressive
campaign that's successful,
we think we can bump that
up to somewhere between five
and seven million
electric vehicles by 2025.
Where we think we need to be by
2025 to meet our climate goals
is more like 10 million
EVs on the road by 2025.
So we really need to
redouble our efforts
and find other stakeholders,
other NGOs, other companies,
government agencies,
that we can partner with
to really focus on
accelerating this market.
So I won't get too much into the
weeds in terms of the policies
that we're promoting.
We can get back to that during
the Q&A session if folks are
interested in , but these are
some of the key strategies that
we think are important.
Public awareness,
which I mentioned.
The consumer incentives.
Workplace charging.
The Department of
Energy has a program
called the EV Everywhere
Workplace Charging
Challenge, which
is a mouth full.
And this is a program
that's working
to recruit about 500 major
businesses around the US
to join the program,
install charging stations
at workplaces, and get
more employees excited
about electric cars.
They did a survey and
found that if somebody
has access to electric
vehicle charging at work,
they are 20 times more likely
to drive an electric car then
the average person.
So clearly these workplace
charging programs
make a difference.
Google is a member of
this workplace charging
program, which is fantastic.
My understanding
is that there are
lots of EV chargers in
California at Google offices.
I don't think, correct
me if I'm wrong,
I don't think
Google has installed
any here in Cambridge.
I know there are few
charging stations around here
but not necessarily
installed by Google.
Somebody in the
audience is saying
zero which means that there
is a need for more charging
stations in the area.
So if anyone is actually
interested in working
with Google to get more charging
stations installed around here,
I would be happy
to partner with you
to connect with the right folks
in your California offices
and see if we can
make that happen.
Public charging infrastructure.
Most people will charge at home
overnight, which is actually
good for the grid too, right?
Because most people are using
electricity when they're awake.
And so if we can
be shifting some
of the load, the electricity
load, to the night,
that actually makes everything
a little bit more efficient.
So that's a good thing.
But it is nice to have access to
public charging infrastructure.
So if you're taking
a longer trip
and you want access to charging
infrastructure along the way
that's helpful.
If you're going to be
stopping at a place
to shop for an hour or
so and want to top off,
it's nice to be able to
have a charging station.
So places like
Ikea are installing
charging stations,
which is great.
And then utility programs.
If you think about the
fact that right now,
the vast majority
of the market share
for the fuel for
our vehicles goes
to companies like
Exxon Mobil and Shell,
and if we can shift some
of that market share
to domestic utility
companies, that
could be a really great
opportunity for these utility
companies to take some
of that market share.
And some utility companies are
starting to figure that out,
that this is a great
opportunity for them.
But we need more of
them to do the math
and figure it out
and also figure out
how to incentivize electric
vehicles through things
like cheaper electricity rates
for electric-vehicle drivers
or cheaper nighttime rates,
which is again, the time when
most people will charge
their electric vehicles.
So I encourage everybody to
check out our website which is
www.sierraclub.org/evguide.
If you go there, you
can click on just
about any electric vehicle
which is on the market.
We're actually
working to update it.
There are few new models that
we haven't gotten up there yet
but we're working on it.
You click on the
car, you find out
some information about the car.
And then it gets interactive.
You put in your zip
code and it tells you
things like how
much money you're
saving in gasoline
versus electricity
costs for fueling your vehicle.
How much gasoline
you're avoiding.
How much oil you're not
using and consuming.
How much you're saving
in emissions, right?
So we've done the
math and figured out
that even with the
emissions associated
with the electricity used
to charge your vehicle,
your electric vehicle
is still going
to be much cleaner than
a conventional vehicle.
You've probably
heard people say,
oh electric cars
aren't so clean.
They're just coal
cars because we're
using fossil fuels
to charge them.
Raise your hand if you've
heard people say that.
Yeah, pretty much
everybody has heard that.
I hear it every day from
Sierra Club supporters
who are understandably
concerned about coal,
and natural gas,
and fossil fuels.
That's great.
We want people concerned about
these issues but rest assured,
we've done the math
and figured out
that even factoring
in the emissions
associated with charging
electric vehicles,
they are still
significantly cleaner
than conventional vehicles.
And in a region
like New England,
that is especially true because
our reliance on the dirtiest
form of electricity, coal,
is actually pretty low
compared to other
parts of the country.
So in Massachusetts, if you are
charging your electric vehicle,
let's say it's a fully
electric vehicle.
It's going to be about
60 to 70% cleaner
in terms of carbon emissions
than a conventional vehicle.
The average conventional vehicle
that you would buy today.
So that's pretty significant
and it's pretty interesting.
So if you go to
this website, you
can find out
information like that.
We also have a quiz.
It's a really short
online quiz that
helps you figure out which
EV might be best for you
based on a variety of factors.
So check out the website.
And now let me tell
you a little bit
about some interesting
opportunities in Massachusetts.
So I serve on the
Governor's EV Task Force
in Massachusetts
which has started
to put in place some exciting
programs and incentives that
make electric vehicles more
appealing in Massachusetts.
And the most exciting
part of that is a rebate.
So that means if you lease or
purchase an electric vehicle
in Massachusetts,
you literally get
a check in the mail for anywhere
between $1,500 to $2,500,
depending on the size of
the battery of your vehicle.
So it's a great opportunity.
Our funding source
for that program,
right now it's a
pilot program, it
looks like it may run out
in the next couple months.
So I would say if you're
thinking of buying or leasing
a car in the next few months and
you're thinking about electric,
now is a great time to do it
before that funding runs out.
We're going to be working to
get that funding source renewed
but there may be a gap period.
So I'd encourage you to
move faster than slower.
And here is the website where
you can find out information
about this program
here in Massachusetts.
So it's mor-ev.org.
Oh, what a coincidence.
I have a picture
here of Brian who's
going to be the
next speaker here.
So as you've probably gathered,
people who drive electric cars,
they love their cars.
They become EV-angelists,
sorry for the pun.
And I've had the good
fortune of meeting
Brian who is a Sierra Club
supporter and member and EV
driver.
And I've had the
fortune of meeting lots,
and lots, and lots
of very excited
enthusiastic electric car
drivers around the country.
And since Brian is
based right here,
we thought it would be great
if he came up and shared
a little bit about
his experience
with his Nissan Leaf.
So why doesn't
Brian come up, talk
a little bit about his
experience, and then both of us
can do Q and A after that.
BRIAN CALI: So thanks very
much and good morning.
I own an EV because I met
Gina actually at another event
that we were at.
And it happened to be
at that perfect time
when I was considering
what we were going
to do with the Prius that
was at the end of its life
and the fact that we
needed another car.
So the timing was
absolutely perfect.
And I came here
today because I think
that early adopters
of technology
play an important role.
And there are some of
you who are already
driving electric vehicles,
which is awesome.
And I'm assuming
that the rest of you
are here because you're at
least somewhat interested.
And so I think it's an
opportunity for those of us
who own to share our
experiences and answer questions
that people may have
so that there might
be some other folks
who decide to adopt.
So actually, I don't have a
lot of prepared statements.
I think really
ultimately the role
is going to be to answer
questions that people have.
But just briefly I'll tell you
about my experience so far.
So we bought our Nissan
Leaf in June of this year.
I did a little bit of analytics
before I came here today
just to kind of take a
look at average energy
consumption and other
things that we were doing
to kind of think about what
the cost impact for us has been
and how that matched up to what
I would expect to have seen.
So before I go into that,
what I will tell you is we've
been really delighted
with the car.
The car gets most of it's
use for my wife actually
who commutes up to Salem
everyday from Arlington, MA.
So she drives up
there every day.
It's about a 29-mile
one-way trip.
She comes back down.
So it's 58-mile round
trip and there's still
miles left on the charge
to get around and run
some other errands every day.
So we have yet to what's called,
"turtling the car," which
is totally running
out of energy and be
stuck on the side of the road.
We haven't turtled once.
You definitely,
as an experience,
you always start out thinking,
how much charge do I have?
And I want to make sure
that I don't use it up.
So you're paying a
little more attention
than you would if you're driving
a gas-powered vehicle where you
can always find a gas
station and get some gas.
So that's definitely
there but you
get used to it very quickly.
I would say that the
surprise that I had is I'm
not really a car
person in the sense
that I'm not all that
interested in buying
high-performance vehicles.
I've never really had, I
drove that Prius I told you
and before that, we drove the
Honda Civics my entire driving
career.
And I will tell you, this Leaf
is really, really fun to drive.
Even as somebody who doesn't
care about those things.
It's incredibly zippy.
In traffic it's really
fun to be able to weave
in and out of things.
It's small, high performance,
that low center of gravity
makes you feel like
when you're going around
turns that it really just turns.
It takes those
turns really nicely.
So it's actually been
really fun to drive.
And we have four
drivers in our house.
And we all fight for the
Leaf, basically whenever
somebody wants to
go on an errand.
So it's a really
fun car to drive.
We looked at some other
ones too at the time.
And for us, again,
family of five,
it really does, and I put
that in my bio that was here,
we can fit our entire
family and our dog who
is a 40-pound mutt
down in the bay
and still feel like,
we're packed in there,
but it's not ridiculous.
We've even done
some trips that way.
So it's a great, I
would say for us,
second car, because we
do take longer trips
as a family and
that obviously where
we get an 80-mile range
in the summertime.
That's the other thing
I wanted to mention
is as we've headed into
the winter and it's cold,
both the performance of
the battery goes down
and you're using
heat which generates
more draw on the system.
And so we're averaging
around more like 60
to 65 miles on the charge
in the winter time.
That's been-- for us in
terms of impact on the house,
in terms of energy usage, it
adds about 250 kilowatt hours
per month.
You probably know
how much energy
you're using at your own home.
We've added on average 250
kilowatt hours on top of that.
Which is interesting
because I also
know the mileage
that we're getting
and I have now figured
out that basically
about 80% of the energy
that we're using to power
our car is coming from what I'm
doing by plugging in our house.
And we're getting about 20%
out at charging stations
that are out and around,
none of which we pay for.
So I know that the system
pays for it ultimately
but the charging stations
at work or in communities
that we're parking at that
are essentially free to us,
they're all
charge-point systems.
I've yet to be charged for
any one of my charging events.
So I'm getting about 20% of
that basically out of pocket.
So I think the other
thing I would say
is we, in contrast
to Gina, are not
able to put solar on our roof.
That would've been a
really nice thing for us
to do to get the notion that
we would be completely powering
our car with solar energy.
There are options.
And the one that I
did for a little while
is the NSTAR Green,
where you basically
pay a premium on top of
your regular electric bill.
Maybe some of you
are doing that too.
Basically what you're
doing at that point
is it's not as if you're
buying green energy directly,
you're subsidizing or
creating a market for energy
that is generated in
more renewable ways.
There's another program that
we're actually using now
through Mass Energy that is
less expensive than NSTAR
Green for us.
And so basically,
we're paying $0.04 more
per kilowatt hour but all
of that is going directly
to pay for wind-generated
energy in this particular case.
We can actually pay
$0.02 per kilowatt hour
and get renewable sources that
are bio-reactor, hydroelectric
local and wind, but we
chose a wind all option
and feel pretty good
about that right now.
So all in all, I would say it's
been a really great experience.
It's a fun community.
So Gina pointed
out, we met earlier.
We met again at the
Climate Change March.
But I'm meeting my neighbors
now that are starting
to drive Leafs and
a BMW i3 showed up.
And a little funny story.
Actually, I experienced
it this morning
but I've experienced it at
other times over where I work,
which is just over
here on Binney Street.
When I first started
driving this car in June,
there was one electric
plug-in Prius and always
a second open spot for charging.
So whenever I drove to work,
which wasn't that often,
but when I did, it was like this
great spot on the first level
of the parking garage and
I could always get it.
And then right after Christmas
time, I started coming in
and there was this BMW i3 that
was parked in that second spot
and it was like, I
can't believe it.
Now there's three
cars in this garage
that are looking
for electricity.
But the funny part
was I met this person
and they live a block
and a half away from me
and we had this
great conversation
about our experiences
with the vehicles.
Again, that sort of
early-adopter conversations
that started.
And just today I drove the
car in because I thought
maybe we could take
some test drives,
get some butts in seats
if people wanted to do it
and so we looked for
parking over here
and there are four
charging stations over here
at the garage on the west side.
And there were four
different electric vehicles
that were parked in each
of those spots, which
is fantastic.
So I love that charging
stations are starting
to be taken up even at the same
time as I hate it right now.
I'd love to see us expand
the number charging stations
locally so we can get
more people to drive in.
So anyway, our experience
has been overall, incredibly
positive.
I really have nothing to say.
It's absolutely true about
the maintenance side.
There's no checking oil.
There's no-- we get
our tires rotated.
We put 1,000 miles
a month in the car
which is exactly what
we're doing with our Prius.
And it's been great.
So I think with that,
we'll take questions.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah,
let's do some Q and A.
BRIAN CALI: And
I'm sure there are
other people with experience
that can share insights too.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Great.
KURT: Can I start
for just a second?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
Yeah, Kurt.
KURT: At Google here
we love metrics.
BRIAN CALI: Yeah.
KURT: So can you talk a
little bit about actual costs,
what the federal rebates
are, how that works
and what the actual--
you mentioned it,
250 kilowatt hours.
How does it work out
in actual dollars?
BRIAN CALI: Yeah, great.
I can do that one first which is
for everybody, your bill maybe
a little bit different.
I'm paying about
$0.13 a kilowatt hour.
So you can do the
math on that one.
It's $30 or so a month
to get 1,000 miles.
And that's the other
thing I wanted to say,
so that was replacing
the car that
was getting 45 miles to
the gallon too, right?
So for me, I need to
tell you it was not
a total straight
up cost equation
about I want to save
money relative to gas.
It is still true that
you can save money,
even at gas at $2.50.
For me, it was
more about, again,
I wanted a car that I
felt good about driving.
I wanted a car that was
taking a step in the direction
that I think we need to
move in as a country.
And simultaneously, we were able
to, again, make energy choices
around where we purchased
our electricity from too
to encourage and create
a marketplace for that.
But all in all,
we're still saving.
And on that calculus,
we save about $30
a month in gas versus
electric straight up.
Even with the premium that
we're paying on our electricity.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
And to add to that,
the average cost of fueling an
electric car in this country,
and obviously it varies based
on the region of the country,
is about $1.25,
$1.30 per gallon,
so the equivalent of that.
So even with today's
low gasoline prices,
that still significantly
cheaper than using gasoline.
You asked about the
federal tax credit.
So that's up to $7,500.
So that's for a full-battery
electric vehicle.
And even some of
the plug-in hybrids
will get you that
much of a tax credit.
Now of course, it also
depends on your taxes.
Not everybody's going to be
eligible for the full amount
depending on all sorts
of complicated factors
about your own
personal tax return.
But I think most
people's experiences
is that they will get the
full tax credit of $7,500.
And the state rebate
here in Massachusetts,
and I know that this is
being broadcast elsewhere,
so the state rebates and
credits are on top of that.
So again in Massachusetts,
it's up to $2,500.
And that's just a
check in the mail.
So it doesn't matter
about your taxes.
That's just a
straight up rebate.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: One quick
comment and one question.
I don't know how
many people here
know about the Google
Drive Now program.
You can go Drive Now.
It's really awesome.
You get the BMW i2.
It's a great option if
you're going Mountain View,
pick one up at the airport.
Actually it's at SkyPark.
It's a one-way rental.
So you go to your hotel-- or
actually, you go to campus
and you can just
take the shuttle
to wherever you're staying.
It's like, it's such a
wonderful experience.
I really recommend it.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Can
you say the name of it again?
AUDIENCE: Drive Now.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Drive Now?
AUDIENCE: It's by BMW.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Great.
AUDIENCE: And the Bay
Area is the pilot city
for the United States.
They have a lot of locations
throughout Germany.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: And it's
like a rental program where
you are using electric
vehicles but you don't
have to pay if you
work for Google,
is that what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: You do pay, but
I think Google gives you
a little-- you get a
discounted rate with Google.
It's actually very
cost-effective
even if you're not an
employee with Google.
So it's a really great program.
But the question that
I have that nobody
has ever been able
to answer it for me,
currently I don't own a vehicle.
So when we need a
vehicle for something
we use Zipcar or
something like that.
We try to get hybrids when
we can but not always.
But given that we use a
vehicle very infrequently
but that sometimes
you have an emergency,
you need to get
somewhere quickly.
My question is, if I charge
the vehicle up and just sort of
let it sit, how long does
it take for the battery
to drain of its charge
when it's not in use?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
Do you want
to answer that for
your own experience?
BRIAN CALI: I can not answer
that because I've never
let it sit that long.
I do remember thinking
about that when we first-- I
did a little bit of searching
on that that suggested,
there's obviously
dissipation over time,
but it wasn't at
an alarming rate.
But I honestly don't remember
what the specifics were.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah,
and in the cold weather,
that would definitely
be an issue.
If you're just letting your car
sit in freezing cold weather,
then the battery
charge is definitely
going to go down faster.
So yeah, if you
expect that you're
going to have the
kind of situation
where all of a sudden you're
going to need a vehicle when
you weren't expecting one,
then this might be a challenge.
AUDIENCE: So let me answer
that a little bit for you.
I have a Leaf.
We've left it for several
weeks and when we got
back it had the same percentage
charge as when we left.
So the main traction battery
doesn't drop much at all.
GINA COPLON NEWFIELD: Is
that even in the winter?
AUDIENCE: Even in the winter
the charge stays the same.
Now if you leave it
outside and it cools down,
as the battery gets cooler, it
has less energy to give back.
It has a little bit
less capability.
But not extremely so.
It always helps if you
can keep it in a garage.
It definitely keeps
the battery warmer
and it just does better overall.
BRIAN CALI: And
the other feature
that my wife and I discovered
that we really liked, which is,
so there's a little app
on Nissan Leaf where
you can basically
while your car is still
plugged in in the wintertime,
as you were just mentioning,
the battery performs
better when it's warmer
so you basically you can tell
it to start warming up the car.
It will warm up the battery
and it will warm up the car
from your house,
so that you're all
ready to go when you
step out in the morning
and unplug it and run.
so that's a pretty nice
to come to a warm car.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah.
BRIAN CALI: With a warm
battery, importantly.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have a sense of what
the overall environmental
impact of these cars
is pertaining to
manufacturing costs?
[INAUDIBLE]
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
Yeah, it's a good question.
So for those who
couldn't hear, he
was asking about the
environmental costs
of manufacturing.
The battery is the
biggest component of that
and so the environmental
impact of advanced vehicles,
where you do have these
sophisticated batteries,
is definitely greater than
with conventional vehicles.
So that is something
important to look into.
But again, when we do the math
and compare the full impact
of conventional cars
to electric cars,
the impact is still lower
for electric vehicles.
One thing I think that's
encouraging about the batteries
is that for lead-acid batteries,
for conventional vehicles,
the recycle rate
for those batteries,
you know once you sell
it for the last time
or turn it in
wherever, is about 98%.
So it's really high for
lead-acid batteries.
We think it's even
higher and will continue
to be even higher
for electric vehicles
because these are very
sophisticated batteries
and there are and
will continue to be
second uses and
third uses for them
in terms of energy storage.
So it may not work well
enough for operating a vehicle
but companies can
use these batteries.
AUDIENCE: Is there actually
a market for that now?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: There
is a small and growing market
for that now.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And actually, my
second question is
what would a gasoline price,
the imagined gasoline price
make these cars
economically compulsive,
given the absence of tax
credits or [INAUDIBLE]?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: You
mean how high would gasoline
have to get?
AUDIENCE: Like would it be
$10.00 a gallon that make this
a no-brainer
decision for people,
even if they didn't care
about the environment,
like the people that
just want to save money?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Right.
Well, I wish I can answer
that question in a simple way
but there are so many
factors involved, right?
So there's the
federal tax credit,
there's the state credits.
It sounds like you're saying
even without any of the credits
there's also whether you're
buying or leasing, right?
And people can get very
attractive monthly leases.
Some people are
getting under $200
a month for leasing
cars like the Leaf
but not everyone necessarily
getting the same lease amount.
Everyone's paying different
amounts for electricity
depending on what
part of the country
you live in or
even as Brian said,
you could choose which
utility program you're using.
So I can't give
you a great answer.
I could make
something up or guess
but I hesitate to do that.
BRIAN CALI: Just on
first principles,
and I think it's a
really good question,
if I think about it from the
math that I talked to you
about, just on a straight
up basis, with gas at $2.50,
we're still saving.
For the amount of
electricity that were paying,
we're still saving money.
And $1.25 it would be a break
even, somewhere in there
it would be a break even.
So I think it partly depends
too on how much would compel you
to say, if I saved $100
a month, would that
make me want to do it?
If I save more or not.
AUDIENCE: Car costs more.
BRIAN CALI: And, what's that?
AUDIENCE: The car costs more.
BRIAN CALI: Well, so that's
what I was going to say.
So actually the Leaf,
I'm happy to share this.
We pay roughly $30,000
for our car ignoring
all the other things
that happened there.
In our case, for top-end Leaf,
I wanted the Bose sound system
so we put it in.
And so, I don't know.
For most of the
cars we were looking
at we would pay around that.
So maybe we paid a little bit
of a premium but not that much.
I think the bigger
thing that would, for me
anyway, that would flip
the switch is range a
is a real issue, right?
So it can't be our
only car unfortunately
because I get 80 miles on it.
If you start to tell me
that I can get 450 miles
and I can charge
it pretty quickly,
and suddenly it's like-- and if
you made that cost competitive,
it'd be fantastic.
But I think for me,
it's-- what's that?
AUDIENCE: We won't see something
like that happen very soon.
BRIAN CALI: Well, so do
you want to speak to that?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yes.
The Tesla Model S already
goes 200 plus miles
on a single charge
and the Tesla drivers
have access to
these superchargers
in many places
around the country.
So that charges
them up pretty fast.
Chevy just announced
last week, the Chevy Bolt
that they're going to be coming
out within a couple of years.
And that's going
to have, we think,
about a similar range
to Tesla but it's
going to be much less
expensive, probably somewhere
around $30,000 even without
tax credits and rebates.
So you know, 200 plus miles.
That's still not the 400.
BRIAN CALI: Well, yeah, yeah.
250 would do it.
I can get to Albany, New York.
There's a pretty lot
of range on that.
As long as, you've got to
make sure there's chargers
when you get there.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
And Nissan has
said that they're
going to be coming out
with a longer-range vehicle.
So we're definitely
starting to see
some new exciting announcements.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Going back to
the previous discussion
about the price break point.
BRIAN CALI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You said
$30,000 was the car price.
Did that include the charging
station installation?
BRIAN CALI: So it didn't.
No.
And I paid, so there's lots of
different ways you can do it.
The dealers will
offer you something.
AUDIENCE: From a couple
years ago when I test drove.
I didn't know if those
had changed or what--
BRIAN CALI: So I paid $500
on Amazon to buy a charger
and I paid an
electrician $125 or so
to come in and install
it into my house.
And so, yeah, if you got it
through Nissan at the time,
it was like a $2,000 thing
with-- yeah, right, right.
So I got it for just around
$500, maybe a little bit over,
and about $125 for
an electrician.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
And what I did--
BRIAN CALI: Say they were
on a 240 line in that case.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
Yeah, and for the Nissan
Leaf or a fully electric
vehicle it makes complete sense
to have what's called
a level two charger.
BRIAN CALI: Right.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: If you
have a plug-in hybrid like I
do, you can actually just
use a regular 110 outlet.
So we don't have a garage
but we have a driveway.
We didn't have an outlet
on the side of our house
next to the driveway so
we had an electrician come
for a couple hundred bucks,
install a regular 110 outlet
and we're good to go.
AUDIENCE: So eventually these
batteries have to be replaced.
How much does it cost to
replace the batteries on these?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah,
that's a good question.
So obviously it's going
to change and develop.
And so I think most
warranties for these batteries
are around eight years.
And so for many people,
after eight years
it'll be time for another car.
I think the vast
majority of people
will not be replacing the
battery for their very car.
But for people who
do, it's definitely
going to be a significant cost.
I can't tell you
for sure what it's
going to be eight years
from now because I think
battery costs are going to be
lower in eight years from now
than there are.
But several thousand dollars.
BRIAN CALI: Great question.
That was our
calculus too though.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I actually wonder
about the eight-year number.
If you think about the
number of mechanical systems
that are in the car and
why I have in the past
replaced vehicles,
and especially, I'm
considering a Tesla which
has an aluminum body.
At which point you're
thinking, you know,
I could see in eight to 10 years
actually replacing the battery
pack on this vehicle
and keep it going.
It seems a little
early, so far, to know
about the longevity
of electric vehicles.
Do you have any
data about longevity
in EVs versus
internal-combustion engines?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: No.
I mean.
I think as you
said, it's too early
to have any good
research on that.
I mean I think we could
get some information
from the automakers.
I don't know how much we
could trust that information
because they obviously
have an interest in it
looking one way or another.
So I think it's
too soon to tell.
AUDIENCE: But we do have
some longevity information
from the hybrids, right?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: For the
[INAUDIBLE] and--
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yes.
So Prius has been doing very
well in terms of lasting long
and most people
will have a Prius,
a regular conventional
Prius, for a lot longer than
eight years without
replacing a battery.
AUDIENCE: And that's going
the opposite direction
in terms of complexity and
number of moving parts.
That's in spite of that.
AUDIENCE: Speaking
of hybrids, we
had a hybrid, looking at sort
of a hybrid solution for us.
We want to go with the
[INAUDIBLE] that we can
but what is the likelihood that,
have you heard about converting
hybrids into the plug-ins?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: There
are people and companies
who do that.
I know of a guy in
New Hampshire who
does that for Priuses
or Prii in particular.
There are kits you
can get, if you
like to do this sort
of thing yourself.
So if you just go to Google and
search for this sort of thing,
you know, Prius or
conversion kits,
or plug-in electric
conversion kits.
Or if you want to find a
company that will do it,
you'll probably find
what you're looking for.
Yes, in the back.
AUDIENCE: If we do go
turtle-up, what do you do?
Get it towed or what?
BRIAN CALI: Yeah, so we're
counting on AAA for us
if that happens.
AUDIENCE: So what does AAA do?
Can they charge on the spot,
or do they tow it, or what?
BRIAN CALI: So
rumor has it, AAA is
starting to encourage drivers
to carry a charging pack where
they'll give you enough
juice to get somewhere.
But we really hope not
to avail ourselves of it
but I think it's
a good question.
Otherwise I think you're
going to get towed somewhere.
So.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So liquid fuel doesn't
necessarily imply fossil fuel.
So what's your opinion
on alternative forms
of liquid fuel that
would [INAUDIBLE].
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: You mean
like bio-fuels or hydrogen fuel
cell vehicles as other example?
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah, I mean,
ethanol is an easy example
to come up with, but
there are other ways
of [INAUDIBLE]
manufacturing [INAUDIBLE]
energy kinds of
chemical processes.
I don't know.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But I presume
that these things exist.
So what's your, do
you or Sierra Club
have an opinion about
alternative liquid fuels
that regular cars existing
could run on that does not
have the same biological
impact, sorry,
ecological impact as crude oil.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: I'll say
a couple things about ethanol.
Ethanol is a very mixed bag,
as you've probably heard.
In some ways, it
is less polluting.
In other ways, there are
significant environmental
costs.
Sometimes the land that
that you have to develop
and the water that you have to
pollute because of the ethanol
production is going to have a
very heavy environmental cost.
So I would say overall, the
environmental advocacy world
is not going all gangbusters
promoting ethanol.
Another thing I'll
say about ethanol
is that a lot of vehicles
are considered flex vehicles.
So you'll see that on a lot
of cars, like Flex Fuel.
The vast majority of these
cars that are flex fuel capable
aren't actually operating
on ethanol or other kinds
of alternative fuels.
So it's a little bit,
it's a whole long story,
but when new fuel economy
standards were negotiated
several years ago, it was
a little bit of a giveaway
to the car companies to say
that they could get credit
for these cars being cleaner
when in reality, most
of these cars were being fueled
by regular gasoline or diesel.
Hydrogen fuel cell
vehicles, we're
definitely keeping
them on our radar.
They're not really a viable
option for most people.
In California, they're
starting to become available,
they're starting to
install charging stations,
But you've got to get the
hydrogen from somewhere
and for most people,
that's from natural gas.
And so whereas
with electric cars,
yes, right now you're
getting your electricity
from a whole range of sources.
They're getting
cleaner over time
because over time we're
shifting to more renewable
sources of power.
If you're getting
your natural gas from,
or you're getting your
hydrogen from natural gas,
that's not exactly
a clean source.
You can get it from solar and
there are some examples of that
and there are some
electric buses.
Hydrogen fuel cell buses
that run on hydrogen
and they get their
hydrogen from solar.
So that's great.
But it's complicated.
So I think we're keeping these
kinds of advances on our radar
screen, but right now we're
most excited about promoting
plug-in electric vehicles
because they're available
and the technology has
really evolved much faster
than some of these other ones.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned earlier
about having businesses put up
the money or take the time
to install charging stations
where their
employees might park.
What's happening
in Massachusetts
to try to increase the
number of public stations?
Are we really relying on
the Googles, the Ikeas,
or other businesses?
Or is there some sort of
incentive and progress there?
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah,
that's a great question.
I'll give a couple examples.
So the Massachusetts
Department of Energy Resources,
I believe that's
the agency that's
overseeing this
particular program,
they have a program
where they'll give grants
to workplaces to offset the
costs of workplace charging.
So for example, I went to a
huge office park in Wellesley,
Massachusetts a few months
ago where they had just
installed 16 charging
stations at their offices
and they got a lot of help
from the state to do that.
So it's a win-win.
If it's a win for the company
to be able to provide this
benefit to their employees.
It's a win for the employees
who can now charge at work.
It's a win for the
state because they
have goals they need
to meet in terms
of reducing their emissions.
So that's a great program.
Google--
AUDIENCE: Will
fuel companies ever
be requested to add
overnight parking
stations at their facilities?
I mean, that seems like
an obvious place, right?
It would be a first
come first serve
but you'd know that you
could park there overnight.
Like, you're not going
to get barricaded in.
You don't have to work
for that business that
pays for that space.
But that seems like a
really interesting avenue,
if people aren't
already pursuing it.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: You
mean a parking garage?
AUDIENCE: I'm Sunoco.
I need to say that n percentage
of my local [INAUDIBLE],
wherever I deliver fuel,
I'm responsible for creating
alternative fueling.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah.
That's an interesting idea.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if
fuel companies are getting
incentives to research
alternative forms.
It seems like a thing that
would help the consumption grow.
It would ease the
burden on people
if they don't want
to, particularly
if they live in an
apartment building
where they can't actually ask to
have someone install a charging
station.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah.
That's an interesting idea.
So in terms of public
charging stations,
the state is also giving some
grant money for public charging
stations.
But I think at this point,
most of the money for that
is being spent by businesses
themselves, either
because they want to
incentivize their employees
or their customers.
Companies like Walgreens are
starting to install them.
BRIAN CALI: I've charged
at Walgreens in Beverly
several times.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Have you?
BRIAN CALI: Yeah.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: I think
that's actually interesting
because usually when
you charge your car,
you want to spend
more than 10 minutes.
I don't know if I've ever
spent more than 10 minutes
at a Walgreens.
BRIAN CALI: That's
right, that's right.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: So
I think it's interesting
that that company in particular
has charging stations.
I think it makes more sense
for a company like Ikea
where you might be
spending an hour or two
and you could get at
significant charge.
BRIAN CALI: Yeah.
The Nissan dealers all have
charging stations as well.
And actually, we've
discovered that they're
right near my kid's
soccer fields.
Very frequently we'll
drive out to Lancaster,
for example, there's a main
soccer complex out there
and we were worried about
taking the Leaf because it
was, one-way it was
40 some odd miles
and if it was a cold we
were a little bit worried.
And then we realized
there's a Nissan
dealer like right
near the fields.
And so we went over and we would
drive out, plug-in the car,
go watch the game, drive home.
Great thing.
So we've discovered
them in strange places.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] reserving
time on the charging stations
to make sure you have a spot?
BRIAN CALI: There are
some that are reservable.
There are some that are
first come first serve.
So that's been my
experience overall.
One of the other things that's
been actually quite nice
is and the Leaf owner
will resonate with this.
It's a great, actually, do
you want to speak to it?
Your experience?
Yeah, go ahead. yeah.
AUDIENCE: Most of the
ones in Massachusetts
that are charge point, on
the charge point network,
you can't reserve because
you don't pay for them.
I think the laws
previously were that you
couldn't resell electricity.
So no one was allowed to
charge you for charging.
I think that's changed
because some of the ones
at Walgreens you actually
do pay to charge.
Generally speaking,
almost all the chargers
are either at a couple of
very progressive companies,
there's like a Stop and
Shop out near Framingham
that has like nine chargers.
But they have a
whole solar roof too.
They've really done
a good job there.
But most of the other ones
are in paid parking lots.
Either at the airport, there are
two level one and two level two
chargers at one of the
parking lots next door.
There's about 12 cars that vie
for parking there at this time.
So unless you're early,
you don't get to charge.
Today I was late.
I'm going to have to look for
charging maybe at 5:00 o'clock
or 6:00 o'clock to get home.
There were two questions
that were asked earlier.
One was the replacement
cost on the battery.
For the Leaf, they've
announced that it's
$5,500 plus installation.
I wouldn't expect to need
that until at least ten years
based on the last
two years of driving.
At 20,000 miles, I've
still got well over,
between 90 and 95% capacity
left on the battery.
And most of the drop
happens the first year
and then it slower after that.
So that should give you an idea
on a roughly $30,000 vehicle,
you're talking about
15%, 15, 20% of the cost
to replace the battery.
There was another question
about if you run out.
I think the other
manufacturer's also have this
but for Nissan, part of
their Protection Plan
is towing in case you
run our of charge.
You have to work at it
to run out of charge.
And once you get the idea
of where you can go and get
your routine going, generally
won't have that issue.
And the only people that it's
really hard for targeting
is apartment dwellers.
If you're at home, you have
a charging station at home.
That's where you can
depend on it every night.
At work it's nice right now when
you can get one of those spots.
If there were more
chargers at work here
and the state plan helped us pay
half of the cost of the $25,000
to install chargers,
that would be great.
Right no we're
sharing four chargers
among a whole lot of
companies around here.
So getting more
installed would be good.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
Just out of curiosity,
is there anybody who is
interested in pursuing
the idea of Google
installing some more charging
stations here in Cambridge?
So if so, let's talk
afterwards because I
can't make any
guarantees obviously
but I can make some
introductions to folks
who might be able to help
you make that happen.
KURT: I had two comments.
One is that we don't
actually own the garage
because they're all shared.
So I don't know how
much that would fly.
The other one is that I
was talking to Steve Vinter
the other day and he says that
there are plans to put chargers
in this building
in the east garage.
How many, when they're
going in, I can't tell you.
But there are plans to
put them in this building.
AUDIENCE: You might have noticed
we're right on the Red Line
here and we have
quite a few people
who don't park in
these garages here
which is good because we're
going to scale up employees
much faster than available
parking is going to scale up.
In fact, it's going to go down.
I personally happen to park
at the end of the Red Line
and I know the MBTA,
whoever they contracted
with, there's a handful
of parking there.
But that's something you might
want to put on your radar
as well is these suburb
terminal parking garages
at the end of the
Mass Transit lines.
Those should be big targets.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Big chargers.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
Great point.
KURT: Are you at Alewife?
That end?
Yeah, me too.
And so actually, so my
experience there is,
they're just now at capacity.
So again, early in the summer,
could always find a spot.
Now it's starting
to get to the point
where there's enough cars
on the road where those,
I think it's six to eight spots,
those fill up in the morning.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD:
So I think we
might have time for one
more question or comment.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you were
talking about going
like 80 miles and whatnot.
But how is it in a commute
that you have to sit-in traffic
and get in to work, even if
it's only 7 or 10 miles away,
you're still sitting in traffic
for half an hour to an hour?
How does that weigh
on the battery?
BRIAN CALI: It's much better.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Great.
So today I was late.
I had to rush in here and I
probably used up about 50%
of the battery capacity
going 22 miles.
That because I was going
maybe substantially
faster than the
recommended limit.
if I was, I could--
AUDIENCE: What
does it really use
when you're kind
of like idling--
AUDIENCE: But if you're
not [INAUDIBLE]--
when you're going, the best
speed to go is about 20 miles
an hour.
If you're in stop and start,
it doesn't use much at all.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: If
you are stopped or braking,
so if you're stopped,
you're using nothing.
If you're braking, you're
actually recharging and adding
more miles to your battery.
AUDIENCE: I had gone, just
recently in the winter,
I've gone over a hundred
miles on the one charge
just because I was
careful and very slow.
You know, slow, maybe
five under the limit.
And that included some
time on the turnpike
so you can stretch it out if
you go slow, drive easily.
And that's stop and go.
You just go at a nice, even
pace and it works really good.
GINA COPLON-NEWFIELD: Great.
Well, thank you
everybody so much.
It was really a
pleasure to be here.
Thank you Kurt for
inviting us to come.
And I think we're going
to be available to chat
over lunch afterwards.
So thanks for having us.
BRIAN CALI: Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]